news daily from science mission
researchers showed for the first time
that only certain sized structures of
misfolded alpha-synuclein proteins
implicated in Parkinson's disease bind
to toll-like receptors in microglia
resulting in the production of
inflammatory molecules hypertension
drugs which can target these receptors
significantly reduce inflammation next
researchers showed that micro RNA 121
year is downregulated in various
autoimmune diseases and chemically
synthesized micro RNA 121a analogue
helps to stabilize the immune system by
modulating t regulatory cells that were
built into the immune system to prevent
excessive reactions next insulin signals
in hepatocytes to activate takt which
inhibits foxa1 suppressing hepatic
glucose production authors in the
journal Nature communications show that
in the absence of foxo1 insulin signals
via an intermediary extrahepatic tissue
to regulate liver glucose production
indicating the presence of extrahepatic
mechanism to regulate glucose production
for more details visitors at www.hsn
calm or science mission facebook page